WELCOME TO THE APRIL TENTH
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING WE HAVE A
HUNDRED AND TWELVE BILLS TO
CONSIDER THIS MORNING.
AT SOME POINT -- WELCOME MR
MCCARTY -- WHO'S FILLING IN FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA.
CLEARLY WE DON'T HAVE.
A QUORUM QUITE YET SO WE WILL
BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE AND
MISTER O'DONNELL I SEE YOU'RE
ALREADY HERE [inaudible]
WELCOME UP.
YOU'LL BE PRESENT IN AB TEN
FOURTEEN IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT AB TEN FOURTEEN WHICH
REQUIRES HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
FACILITIES TO PROVIDE A ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAY NOTICE. TO
THE PUBLIC PRIOR TO DOWNGRADING
CHANGING OR CLOSING THEIR
FACILITIES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS BRO AND WICKS
ARE ALSO JOINT AUTHORS OF THIS
BILL BUT COULD NOT BE HERE TODAY.
THEYTOO HAVE FACED HOSPITAL
CLOSURES IN THEIR DISTRICTS.
A HOSPITAL DECISION TO REDUCE OR
ELIMINATE SERVICES CREATE
SERIOUS CHALLENGES FOR COMMUNITY
UNFORTUNATELY THE NOTIFICATION
TIME FRAMES REQUIRED BY EXISTING
LAW ARE SIMPLY NOT SUFFICIENT.
AB TEN FOURTEEN WILL PROVIDE
COMMUNITY LEADERS WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FULLY INVESTIGATE
ALL OTHER OPTIONS INCLUDING
SECURING A NEW PROVIDER. TO
PREVENT THE CLOSURE OF A
CRITICAL HOSPITAL THAT WAS A
SITUATION OF MY DISTRICT THE
TIMELINE JUST WASN'T LONG ENOUGH
TO FIND ANOTHER OPERATOR.
AT THE VERY LEAST THIS BILL
ALLOWS PATIENTS THE RESIDENTS TO
BETTER PREPARE FOR THEIR NEXT
EMERGENCY NOW THAT THERE LOCAL
HOSPITAL IS GONE AND ALSO PUBLIC
SAFETY BECAUSE PARAMEDICS --
HAVE TO PLAN AS WELL A FIRE
DEPARTMENTS WITH THAT -- HERE TO
TESTIFY MAYBE IS TAYLOR JACKSON
OF THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION SHE MAY BE EN ROUTE
IF NOT -- WE MAY PROCEED I HOPE
[inaudible]
HI THERE.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS
[inaudible]
IN OPPOSITION.
CATHERINE ALSO SCOUT THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WERE IN OPPOSITION UNFORTUNATELY
BECAUSE THE TIMELINE SO I'LL BE
BRIEF AND JUST A WOULD LIKE THE
TIME LINES TO BE MORE IN LINE
WITH THE WARN ACT SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
BERMAN FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO KNOW
ME ASSURE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE DO NOT HAVE A FILE AT
THIS TIME [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
DOCTOR QUIRK.
I'LL BE -- MAKING A MOTION TO
APPROVE YOUR BILL ONE ON
FINANCIAL GROUNDS BUT I DO HAVE
SOME -- POLICY CONCERTS THAT
I'LL TALK ABOUT LATER.
THANK YOU DAVIS RECORD FOR
WILLING TO WORK WITH YOU ON THIS
POLICY CONCERNS.
THANK YOU.
MISTER ROWE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR OF PROUD JOINT AUTHORS
THIS BILL.
YOU KNOW AT A HOSPITAL CLOSE IN
SAN CLEMENTE MY FIRST YEAR HERE
AND SO -- WE JUST FOUND A COUPLE
OF MONTHS NOTIFICATION TO THE
COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENT WASN'T
ENOUGH SO.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT THIS LITTLE
MORE HAPPY TO BE A JOINT
AUTHORED BY CALLING FROM LONG
BEACH.
SEE NO MORE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THAT'S WHAT I WROTE.
SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM WE WILL
TAKE THAT UP THANK YOU MISTER
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY.
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU'LL BE
PRESENTING ON A. B. NINE NINE
EIGHT IT IS ALWAYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WHEN WE ARE ABLE.
TO GET A QUORUM ONE THREE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AB NINE NINE
EIGHT YEAH THE STATE HIGHWAY ONE
TWENTY EIGHT THE LIST OF
HIGHWAYS ELIGIBLE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SCENIC HIGHWAY
PROGRAM.
LEGISLATION ADDING THE HIGHWAY
INTO THE STREETS AND HIGHWAYS
CODE IS THE FIRST STEP OF THE
SCENIC HIGHWAY PROGRAM.
THIS BILL HAS ONLY MINOR COST TO
CALTRANS RELATED TO WORKING WITH
LOCALS ON THE APPLICATION AND
APPROVAL OF HI EVERYONE TWENTY
EIGHT SEGMENTS THAT MAY BE
DESIGNATED.
I'VE HEARD SIGNIFICANT INTEREST
FROM MY DISTRICT TO DO THIS AS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO ATTRACT
TOURISTS AND A BOOST ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY IN THE REGION I ASKED
FOR DRIVE A DO YOU HAVE SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
AND FINANCE.
FINANCE DOESN'T HAVE AN APPROVED
POSITION AT THIS TIME BUT NOTES
THAT CALTRANS ESTIMATES ADORABLE
MINOR COSTS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO COMMENTS. FIFTEEN A
GALLERY OVER HERE THE FEELING
GEHRY HAS TO SHARE HIS COMMENTS
THROUGH BEFORE YES ALL RIGHT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I SIMPLY
ASKED RIVALS.
SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM WILL
TAKE THAT UP THING RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HAVE A GOOD DAY
THANK YOU -- MISTER OBERNOLTE
SEE NO AUTHORS HERE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PRESENT.
YOU'LL BE RESIDING IN AB THREE
NINETY FOUR AND ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- I'M SURE EVERYONE'S
AWARE OF THE DEVASTATING
CAMPFIRE THAT OCCURRED IN
CALIFORNIA LAST YEAR WAS THE
MOST DESTRUCTIVE CAN'T FIRE IN
CALIFORNIA STATE HISTORY.
ALSO THE DEADLIEST IN THE MOST
COSTLY IS DESERT NATIONAL
DISASTER OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN I THINK A NUMBER OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WERE
ALONG ON THE LEGISLATIVE TOUR OF
THE TOWN OF PARADISE IN JANUARY
IT WAS INCREDIBLY POIGNANT. TO
DRIVE THROUGH THOSE DEVASTATED
NEIGHBORHOODS AND SEE ENTIRE
HOUSING TRACTS BURNED TO THE
GROUND. ONE OF THE MOST AMAZING
THINGS ABOUT THAT TOUR WAS THAT
THE WE HAD TESTIMONY FROM THE
FIRST RESPONDERS ABOUT THE LACK
OF EGRESS IN PARADISE SO
PARADISE HAS.
FOR EGRESS ROUTES ALL OF THEM
WERE COMPLETELY PACKED WITH CARS
BECAUSE OF THE RAPID SPREAD OF
THAT FIRE.
AND THEY TOLD US STORIES ABOUT
PEOPLE SHELTERING IN PLACE IN
THE MIDDLE OF INTERSECTIONS AND
THANK GOODNESS THAT THEY WERE
ABLE TO DO THAT BECAUSE
OTHERWISE THAT DEATH TOLL WOULD
HAVE BEEN MUCH HIGHER.
WE HAVE MANY COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA WITH EVEN WORSE
EGRESS THEM PARADISE -- I LIVE
IN A TOWN WITH ONLY THREE EGRESS
ROUTES THERE ARE MANY WITH ONLY
TWO OR EVEN.
ONE SO THIS BILL WILL CREATE A
VERY EARLY VERY NARROWLY CRAFTED
SEQUEL EXEMPTION FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF NEW EGRESS
ROUTES THOSE ARE ONLY IN CASES
WHERE.
THE BOARD OF FORESTRY HAVE
DETAILS DETERMINE THAT THERE IS
A DIRE NEED AND THE AMENDMENTS
TAKE A NATURAL COMMITTEE NARROW
THE BILL SO IT IS VERY
SPECIFICALLY TARGET JUST THOSE
PROJECTS SO I THINK IT'S A WERE
THE BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVE A THANK YOU.
SPEARS IN SUPPORT.
YOUR SINGLE PARTY WITH A
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION --
WE BELIEVE THESE CHANGES ARE
INTENDED TO APPROVE EGRESS ROUTE
SO THAT PEOPLE HAVE THE ABILITY.
TO EVACUATE IN EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS AS WELL AS ALLOW FOR
FIRE SAFETY PERSONNEL TO ENTER
THESE AREAS DURING A WILDFIRE.
MADAM CHAIR CHRISTMAS KAYLEE ON
BE HAVE A HUMBLE AND MENDOCINO
REDWOOD COMPANIES ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NO FILE.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO FINISH UP THAT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME JUST REQUEST
DRIVE OUT ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
UP FOR HIM WE'LL.
TAKE IT UP AS SOON AS WE GET A
QUORUM.
MR GLORIA.
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU HAVE.
TO BILL.
YOU'RE ONLY PRESENTING ON ONE
CORRECT.
AB TWO SIXTY TWO RIGHT.
YES MADAM CHAIR [inaudible] NINE
HE SIGNED UP TWICE.
AB TWO IS A HOLD FOR ONE MINUTE
WE'RE I JUST HAVE TO RESCUE
INTEREST I WAS WARM ONE MOMENT
PLEASE STAND SECRETARY
[inaudible]
GONZALEZ FLETCHER [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
ROOM [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BROUGH [inaudible]
ROOM.
CARILLO.
CHAT.
DE [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
FONG.
GABRIEL YOUR MCCARTY VERY GARCIA.
SIGN.
OBERNOLTE.
PETRIE-NORRIS.
QUIRK HERE READ THIS.
ARE YOU JUST CLARIFY YOU DID
SIGN UP FOR YOUR CONSENT BILL
BUT YOU DON'T WANT TO PULL THAT
OFF CONTENT TO I I DIDN'T THINK
YOU IT.
ALL RIGHT AB TWO SIXTY TWO
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
OF THE BILL.
THE MOTION BY MS CARILLO SECOND
BY WAS THAT MR PEROT OVER THERE
ALRIGHT.
SEAT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS
BILL CODIFIES RECOMMENDATIONS OF
FROM THE AUDIT RELEASED IN
DECEMBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN
RELATING TO THE STATE'S
HEPATITIS A OUTBREAK.
AS ANALYSIS INDICATES THE BILL'S
COSTS ARE MINOR JOHN QUICKLY
ABOUT THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO'S
HERE AS A WITNESS.
JOHNSON CLAIMED THAT THE COUNTY
SAN DIEGO PLEASED TO BE A
SPONSOR THIS MEASURE WITH LONG
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA HERE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
NO FILE.
I SEE NO COMMENTS AND PROUD TO
BE A JOINT AUTHORED THIS VERY
GOOD BILL THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
FORD.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT AFTER I
BROKE THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA
THANK YOU VENTURE.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
MOMENT AND GO THROUGH THE THE ON
CALL BUT NOT ON CALL BILLS BILLS
EVEN TAKEN UP YET AB TEN
FOURTEEN BY MISTER O'DONNELL.
THE BILL WITH.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY THE DOCTOR
QUIRK IS TAKEN BY MISS CARILLO.
AND THAT WILL GO ON CALL.
AB NINE NINETY EIGHT BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY.
MOVE THE BELL SECOND.
THE MOTION BY MISTER QUIRK A
SECOND BY MISTER BRO THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL AB THREE
NINETY FOUR BY MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THE BILL BY MISS CARILLO AS
SECOND BY MISTER QUIRK AND THAT
GETS OUT ON AN A ROLL CALL.
SAYS WE A COUPLE MORE PEOPLE WE
CAN GET THE O'DONNELL BILL OUT
IN THE MEANTIME I THINK IT.
SEAT MISTER LOW YOUR NEXT.
HELLO YOU HAVE AB SIX THIRTEEN
IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS A TO ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
TO MAKE REGULARLY MODEST FEW
JUST MINUTES ACCORDING TO THE
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX WITH ME
INDIVIDUALS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MORE THAN AGO WITH THE BOARD OF
ARCHITECTS IN SUPPORT.
BONE WITH THE BOARD OF ACCOUNTS
IN SUPPORT.
COULD WITNESSES ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT.
YOU CAN WITH THAT CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION WITH THE
SUPPORT OF COMMENDED POSITION --
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE ULTIMATE
DECISION MAKER BE -- SOMEONE
WITHOUT A FINANCIAL INTERESTS
SUCH AS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY IN OPPOSITION.
YOU KNOW SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
NO FILE.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE MR Là.
A RESPECT AS PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISTER I AM IS A BILL
I'M AT THE DOCTOR QUIRK SECOND
SET AND WHAT THAT'S GOING TO GO
ON CALL TO GETS MORE DEMOCRATS
HERE THANK YOU.
MIS READ US. THREE RESCUE ARE
GONNA PRESENT ON AB FIVE TWENTY
FIVE IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION OKAY BILL SEAT
WITH MY MISS CARILLO IN A SECOND
BY DOCTOR QUIRK [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
MEASURE EIGHTY FIVE TWO FIVE
WITH THE CLEAN UP BILL THAT
MAKES A NUMBER OF CONTROVERSY
ALL STATURE TORY CHANGES THAT
THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING IDENTIFIED AS
NECESSARY POLICY UPDATES.
SOME OF THE CHANGES ARE IN
RESPONSE TO RECENT LEGISLATION
OR MAKE ALIGNMENTS LIKE CHANGING
FOREIGN LANGUAGE TO WORLD
LANGUAGE.
THIS BILL SHOULD HAVE MINIMAL OR
NO COST TO THE STATE AND TO THE
COMMISSION THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST I VOTE ON
THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU ARE THEIR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL WITH MR OBERNOLTE NOT
VOTING THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT MR HOLDEN.
COME ON DOWN.
YOU'RE GONNA BE PRESENTING ON AB
TWENTY NINE IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
MOVE THE BILL.
A MOTION MY DOCTOR QUIRK.
NOBODY ELSE IS WITH.
A SECOND BY MISS CARILLO.
IT'S A LONG TRIP BACK FROM EL
SALVADOR IS IN IT.
THANK YOU RESULTING YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF
THIS BILL REMOVES -- THE MOST
DISPUTED LAND OF THE S. R. SEVEN
TEN FROM THE FREEWAY AND
EXPRESSWAY CODE.
OF THE LAW -- IT ALIGNING THE
LAW WITH THE DESIRES OF THE
CITY'S THE FINALIZED CALTRANS I.
R..
LAST YEAR METRO LA METRO
CALTRANS TO CLEAR THE LOCALLY
PREFERRED ALTERNATIVE TO BE A
TRAFFIC DEMAND MANAGEMENT NOT A
FREEWAY.
THIS IS REFLECTED IN THE FINAL
LIES DIR NOW THE COMMUNITIES
THAT USED TO BE AT ODDS OR AT
THE TABLE TOGETHER DISCUSSING
HOW TO MOVE FORWARD TOGETHER.
I PLAN TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE IMPACT OF CITIES AND
CALTRANS TO TAKE THE NEXT STEPS.
ARE WHICH INCLUDES RELINQUISHING
THE LAND INTO THEIR
JURISDICTIONS AND ALLOW THEM TO
DECIDE HOW THE DISTRICT THIS
DISPUTED LAND CONSERVE THE WHOLE
COMMUNITY -- WE ARE AT THE
TIPPING POINT OF A VERY LONG
PROCESS OF SIXTY YEARS OVER THIS
PROJECT AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR THANK
YOU SIR ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CARE ALSO BE HAVE
THE CITY'S A PASADENA SOUTH
PASADENA BOTH IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ARE YOU SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO
FILE [inaudible]
MISS KOREA.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN -- I
SECOND THE MOTION TO MOVE THIS
THIS BILL FORWARD OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE BUT WE STILL NEED TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE
CONVERSATIONS NECESSARY ON THE
IMPACT THAT THIS WILL HAVE ON
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY ONE
WHICH I REPRESENT.
THE NEIGHBORING CITIES HAVE
LOCAL REPRESENTATION
UNINCORPORATED EAST LA DOES NOT
IT ONLY HAS COUNTY SUPERVISOR
AND MYSELF SO IT DOES NOT HAVE
LOCAL INPUT.
CAL STATE LA WHICH WILL BE
SEVERELY IMPACTED BY THE
DECISION OF WHATEVER MOVES
FORWARD.
WITH THIS PROPOSITION IS ALSO
HAS.
HAS SHOWN US YOU KNOW IN THE
MEETING THAT WE'VE HAD.
A LARGE LARGE CONCERNS IN THE
IMPACT THAT THAT WOULD HAVE ON
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THIS BUT WILL HOLD MY VOTE WHEN
IT COMES DOWN TO TO THE FLOOR IF
NECESSARY IN TERMS OF THE IMPACT
THAT IT HAS ON CAL STATE.
LA EAST LOS ANGELES AND THE
NEIGHBORING COMMUNITIES THANK
YOU I THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS.
MR CHOW TOGETHER COMMON AS WELL
YES I US I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY BUT I ALSO LIKE
TO ASK THAT THE AUTHOR TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE CITIES
WITHIN MY JURISDICTION --
HAMBURGER FOR EXAMPLE IN
MONTEREY PARK -- AMONG OTHERS --
AND I THINK YOU STATED EARLIER
THAT YOU WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO
SO LOOK FOR TO WILL CONTINUE
WORKING WITH YOU THANK.
ALL RIGHT NOT YOUR MARCHING
ORDERS.
WE ARE VERY CLEAR IN OUR
MARCHING ORDERS AND WE ARE
CONTINUING THIS.
BILL JUST TALKS ABOUT --
ALIGNING WITH THE DECISIONS THE
CALTRANS IS ALREADY MADE OTHER
GOING FORWARD PART IS WHAT --
THIS AMONG MEMBERS ARE
REPRESENTING AND ARE AND I AM.
FULLY I'M ALL IN ON MAKING SURE
THAT THERE IS -- CONTINUE
CONVERSATION AND COLLABORATION.
SO THAT ENJOYS THE DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I ANTICIPATE SOON
AS WE GET ANOTHER DEMOCRAT HERE
WE CAN GET THAT BILL OUT BUT FOR
NOW IT'S ON CALL THANK YOU
MISTER HOLDEN.
THE REASON SAID AB TEN FOURTEEN
WHICH ALREADY HAD A MOTION AND A
SECOND BY MISTER O'DONNELL NOW --
GETS OUT WITH THE REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING IN MR PEROT AND MR
GET VOTING AYE.
ALL RIGHT WE NEED SOME AUTHORS
[inaudible]
AND MISTER DOCTOR QUIRK I'D LOVE
FOR YOU TO PRESENT YOUR BILLS
THANK YOU.
ARE WE GONNA START DODGE QUIRK
WITH AB FOUR FIFTY SEVEN ENJOY
THE DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
A MOTION BY MS CARILLO.
SECOND A SECOND.
DOING HIS JOB.
BUT AFTER QUIRK THINK IT WILL BE
ONE EIGHTY ON THE COMMITTEE AND
I LOVE YOU ON THIS COMMITTEE.
PLEASE PROCEED.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS TO FINALIZE.
PERMISSIBLE EXPOSURE.
LEVELS FOR LEAD FOR WORKERS BY
DATE CERTAIN.
CALLOW SHE'S BEEN WORKING ON
REVISING THE LEVEL SINCE TWENTY
ELEVEN THE REGULATIONS HAVE YET
TO BE UPDATED EIGHT YEARS IS TOO
LONG TO WAIT.
THE RESEARCH IS DONE THE
ECONOMIC REPORT IS COOL COMPLETE
THIS BILL WILL NOT ANY AT ANY
COST TO THE DIVISION IT JUST
REQUIRES.
THE REGULATIONS TO BE COMPLETED
SO WE CAN PROTECT WORKERS FROM
LEAD EXPOSURE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU DO YOU HAVE SUPPORTERS.
LOOKS LIKE I DO.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS KATIE TONY
DURAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL LABORS HERE IN SUPPORT
OUR MEMBERS PARTICIPATE IN THIS
LEAD ABATEMENT WORK AND FOR
THESE REASONS BUT RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS
[inaudible]
IN OPPOSITION.
YES ROBERT SHE FOR THE CAL
CHAMBER WE ARE IN OPPOSE LESS
AMENDED JUST DUE TO THE TIMING
OF WHEN WE PUSH THESE
REGULATIONS THROUGH WERE IN
TOUCH WITH THE AUTHOR WE THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH US
AND WE'RE HOPEFUL TO BE RESOLVED.
GREAT THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
NO FILE.
ALL RIGHT SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD
YOU LIKE CLOSE.
YES WE WILL CERTAINLY WORK TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE DEADLINE FOR
THE DEPARTMENT IS REALISTIC
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT BILL GETS OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
AT THIS TIME I CAN ALSO SAY THAT
AB TWENTY NINE BY MR HOLDEN --
MOVES OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING TO MISTER OBERNOLTE
VOTING NO IN AB SIX THIRTEEN BY
MISTER LOWE GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL.
MR QUIRK. TWENTY ELEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
THE MOTION BY MISTER OBERNOLTE
IN A SECOND MY MISS CARILLO.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT REQUIRES
PROBIOTIC MANUFACTURERS TO LABEL
THEIR PRODUCTS.
WITH THE GENUS SPECIES AND
STRAIN OF MICROORGANISMS IN
DIETARY SUPPLEMENTS AS WELL AS A
TOTAL ESTIMATED COUNT OF LIVE
ORGANISMS -- CURRENT FEDERAL LAW
REQUIRES MANUFACTURERS TO LIST.
ONLY THE GENUS AND SPECIES NOT
THE STRAIN THE STRAIN.
E. COLI IS IN EVERYONE'S GOT BUT
YOU GET THE WRONG STRAINING YOU
DIE.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW WHAT
STRAIN YOU'RE GETTING -- SO.
WE ARE ASKING FOR THAT AND ALSO
THAT THE THAT THEY LIST THE
COMMON NAME AND QUANTIFY BY
WEIGHT [inaudible]
OF CHOOSE ME BY.
CFU COLONY FORMATION AND UNIT --
ON THE LABEL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
THANK YOU MISTER QUIRK THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU DO I
UNDERSTAND -- MISTER FRASIER'S
AB SIX FORTY IS GOING TO BE
PRESENTED BY MR REVISED.
THANK YOU.
THAT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
NUMBER OBERNOLTE IN THE SECOND
BY A DOCTOR QUIRK THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES I AM
TAKING UP THIS BILL MAY HAVE OUR
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER --
THIS BILL AB SIX FORTY REQUIRES
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES --
YES TO EXPAND EXISTING TRAINING
COURSES -- FOR DEAD.
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S -- IN
THE INVESTIGATION AND
PROSECUTION OF CHILD SEXUAL
ASSAULT CASES.
OF WHICH WILL ALSO COVER CASES
INVOLVING VICTIMS WITH THE
DEVELOPMENTAL -- THAT.
THE DISABILITIES -- RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
THERE'S AN OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NO FILE.
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
THANK YOU.
AT THIS POINT WILL TAKE A MOTION
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
CALDERON A SECOND BY MISS EGGMAN --
MA'AM SECRETARY IF YOU CAN
REDUCE THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AB 1-873-554-4412 FOR TWENTY TWO
FOUR FIFTY FOUR FIFTY SIX BY
FORTY FIVE BY 656-369-77870
280-584-05890 690-290-9913.
916-925-9407 973-109-91890 SEVEN
SIXTEEN THIRTY THREE AND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THANK YOU AND
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
AT THIS POINT WE WILL READ THE
BILLS THAT ARE BEING MOVED TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE MA'AM
SECRETARY.
AB 214-045-17170 518-118-2190
TWO TWO O. 421-322-8250
726-927-1290 730-731-8319.
THREE WHEN I TOOK AN ACCOUNT AT
332-340-3330 238-649-4194
494-044-63460 649-353-1530 TWO
BY THIRTY NINE FIVE SEVENTY TWO
SIX SO. 761-663-5630
865-769-7670 568-713-7327
347-517-83790. 480-081-0830
485-989-4901 907-917-9279
419-404-9599 649-659-67970
298-010-5210 761-081-1114 TWELVE
SIXTY SEVEN FOURTEEN TEN OF
FOURTEEN FORTY THREE AGAIN AS A
CLARIFICATION AB THREE NINETEEN
IT IS NOT BE MOVED A SUSPENSE
IT'S NOT BEING HEARD TODAY -- IF
THERE'S ANYBODY IN THE AUDIENCE
AND HEARD A BILL THAT THEY WERE
INTERESTED IN REGISTERING THEIR
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION TO AND A AT
THIS POINT.
THE FACT THAT THOSE BILLS WERE
CALLED OUT MEANS THE AUTHOR HAS
WAY PRESENTATION YOU DO HAVE THE
RIGHT TO COME UP AND STATE YOUR
POSITION.
ALL RIGHT SEEN NONE WE WILL MOVE
ON I WILL KNOW THAT WE NEED SOME
AUTHORS DOWN HERE MISTER BERMAN
I NOTICED DURING ELECTIONS WHEN
HE CAN GET DOWN HERE.
MISTER -- WHEN -- MISTER RAMOS
OR MISS RUBIO THOSE ARE THE
AUTHORS WERE LOOKING FOR IN THE
MEANTIME I'LL PRESENT MY BILL.
AND I'M CHAIR YOU HAVE AB.
TWO SEVEN THREE MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO INTRODUCE THE
BILL.
SURE AB -- TWO SEVENTY THREE
WOULD PROHIBIT TRAPPING FOR FOR
AND FOR THE SALES OFFER IN
CALIFORNIA.
YOU HAVE WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT I HAVE WITNESSES
SUPPORT.
I'M JENNY KEATING -- WITH THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
AND AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
SPELL IT WOULD PREVENT
EXPLOITATION OF NATIVE SPECIES
WHILE SUPPORTING HEALTHY
ECOSYSTEMS LOCAL ECONOMIES AND
SCIENCE BASED WILD NIGHTLIFE
MANAGEMENT WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
ROBINSON WAS SHORTER AND WE ONLY
HAVE THE HUMANE SOCIETY UNITED
STATES.
WAS ECHO THE COMMENTS THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER WORD SUPPORT.
DEB ACOSTA NEVADA CALIFORNIA
SPORTING A JUST US.
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT IN THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING NO -- KRAMER'S OF
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU.
WE ARE OPPOSED BASED ON POLICY
REASONS I'M WE DO SEE THIS IS
ADDING COST TO OUR MEMBERS --
BUT APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION IN
THE ANALYSIS.
DOES TELL ME ON A ON THE OF THE
KILL FOR GREAT IF YOU
DISSOCIATION WE BELIEVE THIS ONE
BACK TO LIVESTOCK INDUSTRY ON
THE DEPRIVATION ISSUE.
AND AND HAVE COST THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- SEEING NO
OTHERS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE.
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS MR QUIRK.
SO -- THIS IS JUST REFERS TO
NATIVE SPECIES NON INVASIVE
SPECIES.
BUT YES YES YOU CAN STILL
TRAPPED INVASIVE SPECIES --
THAT'S A DIFFERENT LICENSE AND
YOU CAN ACTUALLY STILL THAT TRAP
NATIVE SPECIES THEIR THREAT TO
YOUR PROPERTY OR WELL BEING OR
OR YOUR LIVESTOCK WHICH YOU
CAN'T DO IS TRAPPED IN ORDER TO
SELL THE FOR THANK YOU.%
MISSING MY CHRISTMAS COULD BE
ALONG THE SAME WE HAVE A
INVASION RIGHT NOW OF NUTRIA IN
THE DELTA THAT IS TELLING
THROUGH THE LEVEES -- THAT MUST
BE A THEIR MEAN IT'S GONNA BE
ERADICATED OR WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
BIG TROUBLE.
NOW I DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE FOR
CELEBRATION NOBODY SELLS MAJOR
FOR FROM WHAT I'VE.
ACQUIRED THROUGH MY LIMITED
KNOWLEDGE BUT BUT THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO BE TRAPPED ALL
INVASIVE SPECIES OF COURSE CAN
CONTINUE.
ANYONE ELSE.
MANAGER QUESTION -- SIMILAR TO
MR COURTS.
ARE RECOGNIZING THAT YOUR BILL
ELIMINATES JUST FOR PROFIT --
TRAPPING TRAPPING MAY BE -- MAKE
IT 'LL ISN'T ALLOWED TO USE FOR
DEPREDATION PURPOSES THE SELLING
OF THE HIDE FROM THOSE PRODUCTS
ARE.
IS.
WOULD BE BANNED.
AS WELL CORRECT YES IT WOULD SO
THOSE WOULD JUST BE DISPOSED OF
IN WHATEVER WAY THAT THEY'RE
NORMALLY DISPOSED YES OKAY BUT
NOT FOR SALE.
NOT PERCENT BUT IT'S STILL AN
ALLOWABLE USE NOW WITH RESPECT --
TO THE FOLKS.
ON THAT SPOKE IN OPPOSITION I
KNOW THAT YOU'RE WILLING TO
CONTINUE TO LISTEN AND WORK WITH
THEM. TO FIND WAYS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T HARM BUSINESSES IN
THE PROCESS OF WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE AS WELL
CORRECT RIGHT WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT -- YOU KNOW INDIVIDUALS
ESPECIALLY -- FARMERS AND FOLKS
WHO ARE FACING.
A SPECIES ON THEIR LAND STILL
HAVE THE ABILITY TO TO BRING IN
TRAPPERS OR TO THEMSELVES
TRAPPED ON THEIR LAND WITHOUT IT
THEY DON'T NEED A PERMIT TO DO
THAT -- AT PREVIOUS QUESTIONS
SURROUNDED AROUND URBAN AREAS
WITH HIGH IT IS ALL OF THAT IS
FINE WHAT WE WANT TO STOP IS
TRAPPING FOR THE SALE FOR WHICH
IS BY THE WAY A VERY -- SMALL
SUBSET OF OF THE TRAPPING THAT
HAPPENS IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE
THANK YOU THAT BILL GETS OUT ON
A B. ROLL CALL WITH MR FUNG
MISTER DEEDS OF STANDING
.
YOU HAVE AB.
SIX FORTY FIVE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
BEGIN 2%.
THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
DENTURE WOULD LIKE TO TAKE OVER.
FOR SO THIS WILL JUST REQUIRING
OPPOSE -- THE REQUIRE THE
POSTING OF THE NATIONAL SUICIDE
PREVENTION HOTLINE ON AN
EXISTING LABELS ON GUN PACKAGING
FIREARMS SAFETY CERTIFICATION
EXAM AND NEW SIGNS IN GUN STORES.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIDE OUT
THANK YOU ANY SPEAKERS AND
SUPPORT.
JACK ANDERSON WITH THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S SIXTY ONE LOCAL
DEPARTMENTS AND SUPPORT.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR --
CAPPING LYNCH REPRESENTING THE
NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION WE'RE NOT REALLY HERE
OPPOSED TO THE POLICY -- WHAT I
DO WANT TO EMPHASIZE IS THAT WE
JUST CHANGE THIS LAW LAST YEAR?
WE JUST PUT INTO EFFECT NEW
WARNING LABELS THAT ARE REQUIRED
ON PACKAGING.
THAT JUST WENT INTO EFFECT IN
JANUARY AND NOW WE'RE CHANGING
IT YET AGAIN THIS IMPACTS.
ALL THE INDUSTRIES THAT SHIP IN
THE CALIFORNIA SO THERE'S A
BUSINESS IMPACT THEIR BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY WHAT I WANT.
TO INFORM THE COMMITTEE OF IS
THAT THE NATIONAL SHOOTING WE
ALWAYS GET CRITICIZED FOR NOT
DOING THINGS.
BUDGET AND YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU UNDERSTAND THIS IS A
FISCAL YESTERDAY ON MEANS OF HOW
IT AFFECTS THE STATE FISCALLY IS
IS WHAT YOU'RE WELL.
YEAH BUT WHAT I WHAT I WANT TO
POINT OUT IS THAT THE NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION AND
THE AMERICAN SO SUS.
SOCIETY FOR A SUICIDE PREVENTION
HAVE JOINTLY SPONSORED A PROGRAM
NATIONWIDE TO GET INFORMATION
OUT ABOUT SUICIDE PREVENTION
INCLUDING ALL KINDS OF
COMMUNICATION.
THAT'S POSTED EVERYWHERE AT
RETAIL AND THIS BILL ACTUALLY
COULD UNDERMINE THAT BECAUSE YOU
TO HAVE CONFUSING POSTING THEY
MIGHT PULL OUT THEIR ADVERTISING
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I KNOW THAT -- THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN IS CONCERNED ABOUT
VETERANS IN PARTICULAR AND THAT
THE INFORMATION IN THE SUICIDE
PROGRAM THAT OUTLINED COVERS
VETERAN TESTS HOTLINE NUMBERS IT
HAS A WHOLE HOST OF THINGS.
SO I JUST WANTED TO BRING THAT
TO THE CONVERSATION BECAUSE I
THINK THAT THIS WORK IS UNDER
WAY IT'S REACHING A LOT OF FOLKS
AND I'D HATE FOR CALIFORNIA TO
GET CUT OUT OF THE EQUATION
THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
[inaudible]
NO FILE.
WE DON'T CLOSE -- I'M SORRY
[inaudible]
YEAH.
THE AUTHOR COULD YOU ADDRESS
THAT COMPONENT BECAUSE AS I
UNDERSTAND IT.
A LOT OF THESE QUESTIONS THAT
ARE TO BE ASKED ABOUT.
MENTAL HEALTH ACTUALLY ALREADY
EXIST IN THE CURRENT -- ACTIONS
LIKE IF YOU GO TO PURCHASE A GUN
AND YOU HAVEN'T DONE THAT IN
AWHILE BUT YOU THE TICKET
COUNTER SAFETY COURSE YOU DON'T
HAVE PROOF.
IF YOU TAKE A THIRTY QUESTION
TEST IT DOES IDENTIFIED THE
QUESTIONS ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH IN
THERE YOUR BILL REALLY PERTAINS
MORE TO SPECIFIC -- SIGNING
COULD YOU ADDRESS THAT.
OF YES I CAN ADDRESSES SO I MEAN
THE BACKGROUND IS THAT I HAD A
DEPUTY FROM MY DISTRICT APPROACH
ME -- HIS BROTHER WHO IS A
VETERAN HAD TESTS -- COMMITTED
SUICIDE USING A GUN AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT HE SAID WAS THAT
THE HE DID NOT HAVE QUICK ACCESS --
TO ANY SERVICES SO THE THE
NATIONAL SUICIDE HOTLINE HAS --
IF HE HAD JUST HAD THAT NUMBER
AND BEEN ABLE TO PUSH ONE FOR
VETERANS IT'S POSSIBLE THAT HE
WOULD HAVE GOTTEN.
SOME INFORMATION.
THAT WOULD HAVE SAVED THEM AT
LEAST THAT'S WHAT HIS BROTHER
THINGS SO THIS IS THIS IS --
THIS WOULD BE A SEPARATE SIGN
THAT YOU JUST HAS THE THE
SUICIDE HOTLINE NUMBER.
IT WOULD BE -- THE PHONE NUMBER
AT THE BOTTOM OF THE EXAM AND IT
WOULD BE -- PACKAGING GOING
FORWARD THAT JUST SAYS NATIONAL
SO AT ALL THE SUICIDE HOTLINE
NUMBER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
I APPRECIATE FOR THE CLARITY.
RIGHT NOW AND YOU KNOW THE
APPROPRIATIONS AND ALSO STATES
THAT THERE ARE NEGLIGIBLE COSTS
SAID BUT I THINK THIS IS THIS
COULD POTENTIALLY PROVIDE
VALUABLE INFORMATION -- THAT
CONSISTENT INDIVIDUAL IN CRISIS
SELF RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
MICHAEL THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING AFFORD THAT GETS OUT ON
A ROLL CALL.
MISTER GROWING MISTER FONG NOT
VOTING THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER [inaudible]
MISS RUBIO.
YOU'LL BE PRESENTING ON AB
ELEVEN EIGHTEEN IT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION [inaudible]
THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MS CARILLO.
A SECOND BY MISS EGGMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE ONE ONE EIGHT THE EACH
FRIENDLY CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND HAS A SMALL ONE TIME COST
ESTIMATE OF JUST NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THIS ESTIMATE INCLUDES COSTS FOR
STAFF ADMINISTRATION OUR REGION
TRAVEL NESS -- NECESSARY FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL. FOR
SUCH A SMALL PRICE AB ONE ONE
ONE EIGHT WILL HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT AND LAUNCH
CALIFORNIA INTO THE FUTURE AS A
MEMBER OF A OUR PEACE EACH FROM
THE NETWORK -- WITH ME TODAY I
HAVE -- BLANCA CASTRO -- TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
OR FURTHER DISCUSS THE AGE FROM
THE NETWORK -- IF YOU ARE
INTERESTED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M DO YOU WANT TO
JUST ANSWER QUESTIONS IF ANYONE
HAS A MURDER I'D LIKE TO JUST
MAKE A QUICK SHIPMENT ON BEHALF
COR A. R. P. -- I'M THE ADVOCACY
DIRECTOR MY NAME IS BLANKA
CASTRO -- WE REPRESENT THREE
POINT THREE MILLION MEMBERS HERE
IN THE STATE AND JUST WANTED TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT WE HAVE BEEN.
FIRST OF ALL VERY GRATEFUL TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO FOR
WILLING TO CHAMPION THIS ISSUE.
IT IS SIMPLY GUIDELINES IT IS
NOT MANDATING LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ON DOING ANYTHING.
BUT REALLY PREPARING LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS FOR THIS AGING --
POPULATION THAT IS GOING TO BE
BOOMING -- AND BY TWENTY FIFTY
WE WILL SEE A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE -- ONE ONE COMMENT I DO
WANT TO MAKE IS THAT WE DID MEET
WITH THE OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH AND THEY HAD NO
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CURE ROSS ON BEHALF
OF THE MARIN COUNTY COUNCIL OF
MAYORS AND COUNCIL MEMBERS AND
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE AYE AYE GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
MS BETWEEN OURS YOU'RE NOT HERE
TO PRESENT SOMETHING ARE YOU
OKAY GOOD.
DID NOT HAVE YOU ON MY LIST --
YOU'RE ON THE COMMITTEE.
I'LL GET IT RIGHT SOONER OR
LATER.
IT'S ONE OF OUR NEW MEMBERS
WELCOME SHE'S ONLY BEEN HERE.
FOR A FEW MONTHS OUT.
I JUST GET NERVOUS MY LOOK OUT
AND THERE'S A MEMBER THAT I
DIDN'T ANTICIPATE SO WE ARE
LOOKING FOR MISTER BERMAN AND
MISTER RAMOS I KNOW OF MISTER
BERMAN IS IN A COMMITTEE -- HAS
A NUMBER OF BILLS SO -- IF
ANYONE.
WEARING GIVE THEM A FEW MINUTES
.
ALL RIGHT JUST TO MOVE THINGS
GOING ON WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
MISTER QUIRK PRESENT ON MR
ALMOST AS BILL SINCERITY HEARD
IN PUBLIC SAFETY AND APPARENTLY
MYSTERONS DID NOT KNOW HE HAD A
BILL UP SO.
THAT SOLVES THAT PROBLEM.
IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AB.
FOR THIRTY THREE A MOTION BY
MISTER OBERNOLTE A SECOND BY
MISS CARILLO.
SEE THIS BILL REQUIRES A
PROSECUTOR BE GIVEN TWO DAYS
WRITTEN NOTICE OF THE HEARING.
FOR EARLY TERMINATION OF
PROBATION AND REQUIRES UP HERE
HE IS -- GREAT RESTAURANTS AND
MR QUIRK WAS GOING TO PRESENT ON
YOUR BILL THAT YOU.
WE IT'S ALWAYS BETTER.
YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
COME ON UP.
THAT MEANS IT'S A QUICK.
AND BY THE WAY MOTION BY
REPUBLICAN A SECOND BY A
DEMOCRAT THAT SHOULD TELL YOU
WHERE THINGS ARE GOING S. REAR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
HE LEARNS CLICK.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO QUESTIONS THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL THANK YOU MISTER
ROBERTS YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN DO WE
KNOW HE'S GONNA BE ONLY
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible] FIVE THIRTY YOU
MIGHT.
MR COURSE GONNA -- SEVEN FOR
MISTER BERMAN.
WE'RE GONNA START WITH.
AB.
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT THERE'S A
MOTION BY MISTER OBERNOLTE A
SECOND BY MISS CARILLO.
YEAH THIS BILL SEEKS TO MAXIMIZE
CAL FRESH BENEFITS FOR LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
BY SIMPLIFYING THE VERIFICATION
OF THEIR HOUSING EXPENSES.
NO THAT WAS FOR NINETY FOUR BUT
STORY AND I ALREADY.
ATE THIS BILL PERMITS A NURSE
PRACTITIONER AND PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANT. TO PERFORM A MEDICAL
EVIDENTIARY EXAMINATION AND
UPDATES TERMINOLOGY.
DOCUMENTATION PROCEDURES AND
TRAINING CURRICULA FOR MEDICALLY
EVIDENTIAL. FOR MEDICAL AT
EXAMINATIONS IN CASE OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
THANK YOU MISTER PARKER THEIR
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
YES MY NAME IS KIM LOCKER ROOM
AT THE CALIFORNIA SEXUAL ASSAULT
FORENSIC EXAMINER'S ASSOCIATION
WE'RE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HILLARY LARKIN FROM THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY SEXUAL SLOW RESPONSE TEAM
RUN SUPPORT.
GREAT.
RESIDENTIAL SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE.
ALL RIGHT THAT GETS OUT ON IT A
ROLL CALL THANK YOU MISTER PARK.
YOU COULD WORK.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO PRESENT IF YOU
CAN'T PRESENT ON ON THE CAL
FRESHMAN ON THE FOUR NINETY FOUR
YES WITH THE IT'S A SENSIBLE
BILL -- I EVEN HEARD THAT PART
OF IT ALREADY THE POINT HERE.
WE SEE HERE THANK YOU MISTER
BERMAN YOU CAN THANK MISTER
QUIRK FORGETTING OUT YOUR AB --
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT WE'RE JUST
STARTING ON AB FOR NINETY FOUR
IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION.
BY MISS CARILLO IN A SECOND BY
MISTER QUIRK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
MISTER QUIRK FOR FOR PINCH
HITTING FOR ME.
AB FOR NINETY FOUR MAXIMIZE
CALPERS BENEFITS FOR LONG
CALIFORNIANS BY SIMPLIFYING THE
VERIFICATION OF THE HOUSING
EXPENSES IT'S A GOOD BILL AFTER
I'VE [inaudible]
EXACTLY RIGHT.
JESSICA BARTOLO WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY AND SPONSORS
SUPPORT.
GET THE MOST FOR CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS IN
SUPPORT.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NO FILE.
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE THAT
GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING BUT AND MR DIEM IN MR
OBERNOLTE BETTING HI.
BRIDGET THANKS VERY MUCH THANK
YOU.
I BELIEVE YOU ARE OUR LAST
AUTHOR AND SO THAT WILL CONCLUDE
OUR APPROPRIATIONS MEETING.
I AM GOING TO HOLD OPEN THE ROLE
FOR JUST A FEW MINUTES TO SEE IF
MISTER BLOOM -- IS IS GOING TO
CHECK IN -- MAYBE OF HIS STAFF
IS WATCHING WE CAN GET AN IRON
AYE BUT ALL WAIT FOR ABOUT THREE
MINUTES THANK YOU